my subject today
is multiculturalism
and together with luke hogendern
i did a study of multiculturalism in the
netherlands
um and um
as soon as pointed out
we had the advantage of of doing this
study too soon
um
we carried out our survey actually two
years before um
the eruption over multiculturalism and
the uh the explosive entrance of
pimportaine onto the political stage
so why why do i say we did the study too
soon
because our results demonstrated how
deeply divisive multiculturalism is
and it was
deeply divisive
before
pym four time
before 9 11 for that matter
which is to say uh
not because of them
and when i say deeply divisive i mean
something
quite specific
characteristically when
there's a conflict in a society over
an issue of tolerance
the cleavage the fault line runs between
center
and
periphery between those who are at the
margin of the society who are poor and
who are poorly educated
those with extreme views
the alienated
versus those who are at the center who
are
well educated integrated
well off in the mainstream of society
but what marks multiculturalism
as a conflict
of a special kind
is that the cleavage runs through the
center of the society
um so
by way of an example
when a circumstances make
considerations
of national identity salient
even those who ordinarily are not
concerned about issues of identity
are just as likely
to react against immigrants
as those who are concerned about them
that that was
the
gist of our account
and
boy and this i'm happy to underline
subsequent studies have replicated it
the analysis above all of the 2001
election by uh dutch political
scientists
which
that's the election in which pim fortine
came from nowhere and just surged
uh to the front
and uh and and but for being
assassinated would have been prime
minister
um
the the support that carried him almost
into the prime minister's office
uh came was it it wasn't because there
was a revolt of the alienated and the
intolerant
it was because of a huge stream of
support from those who
are at the center
of society
and
it's just because multiculturalism has
pitted those who are at the center of
society against one another
that it has
as it has been
implemented
politically failed
and i want to emphasize as implemented
because
i have two concerns today
the first is to try and probe more
deeply
one of the principal reasons
that
multiculturalism is said to evoke
opposition
and the other is to see if i can
identify some conditions under which
it can be widely acceptable
now some of the reasons why
multiculturalism um evokes opposition
are just um
self-evident prejudice is a good one
ideology is another no no no not
carrying quite as much weight as one
might think
but
but the particular theme
that i want to focus on is
goes under the heading of the clash of
cultures
and that's not that's an idea whose
meaning appears
reasonably straightforward
but in fact
is deeply ambiguous
and i'm going to uh
explore three different interpretations
of what one might mean by a clash of
cultures
and i mean to show you that
the one that matters
has
nothing
to do with culture
now multiculturalism can mean
so many different things that i need to
get a foothold
i mean it's consensually agreed that it
requires more than a willingness to
accept to tolerate to put up with
a cultural minority
so at least as a starting point
i'm going to define multiculturalism as
requiring a commitment to the right
emphasis on the word right
of a cultural minority
to follow their own way of life
and the case that i'm going to consider
is
muslim immigrants in the netherlands
that figure shows you the level of
support
for multiculturalism defined as the
right of muslims to follow the muslim
immigrants to follow their own way of
life in the netherlands
manifestly
there's
many that reject that idea
and those who reject their idea there's
more of them
that feel strongly about it
then uh
supporters of multiculturalism feel
strongly about their position
even so
there's a majority
bare majority as it happens 54 percent
who
align themselves uh with uh the idea of
multiculturalism
um
which is i think really
uh
remarkable when you consider the storms
that
have erupted over that issue
but of course
all that i do is ask people questions
and as it were write down their answers
and um
and surely one has to
ask oneself
what does it actually mean
if you say that you accept the right of
muslim immigrants to follow their own
way of life
after all it doesn't take much to say
yes
and
and then the question is
is
this
meaningful
um
so so what what would count
as a criterion for
someone taking a position and
we
counting it as meaningful support for
the position
well a natural way to think about it
anyway the natural way for me as an
american to think about it is that a
member of a majority is
is good-hearted enough to want to go out
of their way to see that
the
members of our cultural minority
do well in their new society
and i think that um that that's actually
a a route to go
in an american context
but it's it's not
so
telling an expression of support in
the context of
a european welfare state
there's just the norm of the idea that
that that those who have some
need should
get the um
that the state should play
a supportive and nurturing role
and
illustration
question whether or not children of
ethnic minorities should receive extra
attention at school
and
the answer is
yes yes yes yes yes
that's what
all
but
a small minority say
so then what we were thinking in
designing the study is
how can you tell if somebody
is committed to a position well one way
to tell is can they will they do they
want to stick to it
even when they're put under pressure or
given
a good reason
for changing their mind
so immediately after those
who took the position that they uh
supported
uh the i the prep the policy of giving
extra assistance
uh to um minority ethnic minority
children in school immediately after
they took that position then the
interviewer said to them something on
the order of
well but what about dutch children
there
many of them have problems that are are
just as serious as the children of
ethnic minority
does that change your mind
which was the best counter argument that
we could think of at the
time and um and as you can see
uh just a small proportion of those just
a little bit over one in five
uh of those who had said that they
supported extra assistance for the
children of ethnic minorities flip over
whilst those who are strongly opposed to
the right of
muslim immigrants to follow their own
way of life in the netherlands
about one out of every two
is willing to abandon the position that
they just took
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna start
on the presumption that our measure of
multiculturalism of support for
multiculturalism is measuring something
that is meaningful
that it's capturing as seen perfectly as
survey measures always
are imperfect
captures of any sentiment but
nonetheless it's capturing something
that represents a genuine commitment
on the part of many
which
therefore allows us to ask what is it
that makes multiculturalism so divisive
and
why do those who reject it reject it
and i want to concentrate on the
factor that's gotten the most concern
and that is the so-called clash of
cultures
and so-called is not the happiest choice
of words
since there is in fact a clash of values
here is an item asking
whether or not muslim men dominate
their women
and uh there is
overwhelming agreement
among the national majority
that yes indeed they do on the order of
nine out of every ten
here's another example do muslims in the
netherlands raise their children
in an arbitrary way
answer again on the part of an
overwhelming majority here on the order
of about four out of every five
yes indeed they do
now it happens
that
the
difference of views is reciprocated
from a sample of muslims in the
netherlands the same two items were
asked except flipped around
and an overwhelming majority of muslims
take the position that western european
men do not show the proper respect
for women
and by an almost similar margin
that
western european parents are just too
lax and permissive in the ways that they
raise their children so there is
genuine differences
about what's right
and proper
when it comes to how we should behave
towards each other
towards our children
and what the status of women is
but
does that have anything to do
with the conflict over multiculturalism
and
before i showed you the figure you know
that the answer is
no way that it could have
since
the agreement the
taking exception to
the norms of how women are treated
chimney children are treated among
the dutch
is virtually unanimous
it could not possibly explain
why some
support
multiculturalism
and others oppose it
no more than any constant can explain a
variable
but
but but the conflict of values may take
place at
at a different level
and maybe it's not the values uh that
define what are uh
socially mandatory ways to treat each
other
maybe what it has to do with and
it's the is the core values of liberal
democracy
um
and and that's an argument that's now
been put on the table
and and so with apologies
for kind of
mercilessly compressing
arguments that are
are genuinely nuanced
the person that i have in mind here is
uh joseph ross
and roz has uh has argued i think
eloquently
that personal autonomy is a linchpin
of liberal democracy
individuals on his view
must have the capacity and the right
to develop their their talents and their
outlook on life
as they freely choose
and for just this reason
there's
multiculturalism argue
autonomy as a value
undercuts
cultures like those of muslim immigrants
which are grounded on the priority of
the claims
of the community
not individuals
so to test that we developed a measure
of uh the importance that people attach
to autonomy it has a number of different
components um
the importance of freedom of thought and
action
independence
equal opportunity
and developing one's
individual
talents and abilities
now if the claim of um of some theorists
of multiculturalism is right
then it ought to be the case that
the stronger support
is given to the value of personal
autonomy
the stronger the opposition to
multiculturalism
and and that
line of reasoning just like the first
turns out to be empty
there's just virtually a flat line
that's running across that middle panel
those who support those
support multiculturalism those who
oppose multiculturalism
are just about equally supportive of the
value of personal autonomy
there is though a third version
of the clash of cultures argument and
this one is more social psychological
on this
third line of reasoning
the clash of cultures is only indirectly
about
culture um
it doesn't really touch the conflict of
the
values of western europeans
and those of
muslims
rather what's
at work is the threat
that some in the majority perceive
to the identity of their culture
and what counts is a perceived threat
not an actual threat
and just so far as that line of
reasoning is valid then it should be the
case that
those who are
more disposed to perceive a threat to
their culture their cultural identity
will be more likely to oppose
multiculturalism
and yes indeed such is the case
it means just move up sharply as you go
from left to right
and
those who are most strongly opposed
to
multiculturalism
are also most likely to perceive
that their cultural identity is under
threat
okay
but that's just an opening
because the question then becomes
what actually is threatened
what do they see
as being at risk
and a literal interpretation is that
it's the values of their culture
that they perceive to be threatened
and um and on the argument that i've
offered you
no value is more important
in a liberal democracy than personal
autonomy
so here you see a regression
readiness to perceive a threat to
culture to your cultural identity on
the measure of autonomy those that's an
unstandardized coefficient
and
and yes indeed there is a relationship
but it's just the other way around
those who are
more supportive more committed to the
value of autonomy
are less likely to perceive
that
the
cult that their cultural identity is
under threat
um
when it comes to the um the swirl of
sentiments um
around um
a majority's aversion to a minority
things are are often not what they seem
and even sometimes they're the opposite
of what they seem
and here is a nice example because an
insistence on the value
of one's country and the necessity for
vigilance to protect its
identity actually goes hand in hand
with
suspicion and disdain and contempt
for fellow members of the in-group
here's a measure of the extent to which
dutch
perceive their fellow dutch to be
lazy and aggressive and complaining
and
and those who are most likely to say our
culture is being
put at risk by those outsiders are also
the very people who are most likely to
dislike their fellow insiders
and
and that's actually a not a bad clue
for what's going on
and what it is that uh perception a
readiness to perceive your cultural
identity to be
uh threatened by outsiders
what it actually signifies
um there's a paradox um to chauvinism
um you know in at least in a liberal
democracy
those who us who are ostentatiously
who
the ones who take the most pride in
their country
are also the most likely to be
aggressive
to be hyper nationalists
and so when you
add a measure of chauvinism
you can see that um it leaps to the
front of the parade
as
as a measure that is a signal of what it
is that
perceiving a threat to your culture is
actually measuring
um
and that result
suggests um a final test
because once you realize that chauvinism
is um is involved
somehow
um in um
reinforcing a readiness
to feel threat
um
it's it's it's it's a it's a signal that
what may be
at play here is the susceptibility to we
they thinking
so
as a final
component we had a measure of prejudice
towards
immigrants
and
it and chauvinism
are the heart of the matter
that is
what is being captured
by
this
perception that our culture is under
threat
it's not a commitment to that culture
it's readiness to be intolerant
now i want to turn to the positive side
of of this project
and and the and and the goal is to try
and identify some conditions under which
multiculturalism
is more widely acceptable
and this part of the project is in
is in progress now
um
so what i'm going to report
are genuinely preliminary results
chauvinism and prejudice measures
is that that's not prejudice against the
immigrants that's just general prejudice
sure
uh let me say more than a couple of a
few a few words okay um there there is
um um
a set of findings that are strikingly
robust um which show that
people who perceive
a threat to culture
are for that matter a threat to their
personal economic well-being or for that
matter a threat to the economic
well-being of the society
or for that matter
a threat to personal violence or for
that matter a threat
violence in the society as a whole
are
more likely to be prejudiced against
immigrants
which is not at all surprising
considering that actually those test
items
read
do you feel
that
immigrants
are a threat
to your
personal economic well-being to the
well-being of the country and so on so
in in in the measurement of threat
itself
the standard
um uh items
uh inc always include a phrase by
immigrants by a minority and so um our
notion was that uh that those findings
are so robust the reason is that they're
taught logical
you're just
measuring the same thing
so uh in the dutch study uh we one of
the experiments that we did
was uh we called the
decoupling experiment half the time
uh the threat measures were used in
their standard
formulation and half the time
there was no reference at all to
immigrants
when there's a reference to immigrant
every threat is correlated with
prejudice
highly and
at about the same magnitude
with one one one exception but of the
five four are interchangeable
on the other hand
when you don't
make the relationship a tautology
then one threat stands out above all the
other threats and that's a threat to
cultural
identity um
it is true that concerns about economic
well-being
um are not trivial
um
but they don't match in magnitude the
association with um
with cultural identity
so and one one other
cautionary note
um
when the study was done it was a time of
um of prosperity
and um
and one of the reasons that i feel such
a great need to go out and um
and
start all over again
is because it's a different world in
which
people in western europe are living and
for some of them it's just
an altogether different world
and
concerns economic concerns
which were secondary
um i have to believe have now become
much more prominent in
people's uh inorganizing peoples
thinking about politics and immigrants
um
so
but on the positive side now
good news side
um
i want to go back to what it is that
multiculturalism might mean
and this is taken from
a work by george crowder
which is unhappily i think the book has
the title of a textbook on
multiculturalism
which is unfortunate since it is the
clearest
most
strongly argued
analysis of multiculturalism of which
i am aware
so um
it's a sequenced
definition um
the the first requirement
uh all that's required is a recognition
of cultural pluralism that's not going
to get you very far
the second condition is a little bit
more challenging
um
because it does make clear that there
has to be some affirmative
response it's not good enough just to
acquiesce
in cultural pluralism
but it's the third
condition which
i think clearly constitutes what the
hurdle is
and that's public recognition
um
and
and and it's the meaning of public
recognition
that um that i'm trying to um unpack
and i want to
uh just
by way of um
of a of a warning say um
it's not clear to me
how
precisely to think about the problem
i'm going to i'm going to talk about it
as though what
the the research problem is to find
where citizens draw the line
between what's acceptable and what's not
acceptable
and as a as a as a way to get
going that seems to me really
useful
uh but in the end i think it's the wrong
metaphor
um i think that um
that if if we can succeed
in the task that's ahead
um we'll know that we've succeeded when
we come out and we can identify a
gradient
something that's continuous
about how far citizens are are willing
to go
but
initially it seems to me there there are
um
three lines that that stand up
and one possibility is that um
the majority box at uh forms of public
recognition
that entail an acknowledgement of a
change in the status quo
um another is that the majority draws
the line at actions even even symbolic
actions
that signal a change in the balance of
power
between majority and minority
and a third is that the crux isn't so
much a change in the status quo
or even an implied loss of power
but it's a challenge to ownership
whose country
whose culture
ours
or theirs
uh now
for those of a certain
age um
you should
recall
recall a um one of the the the real um
where the battle over multiculturalism
america took place and that was over
textbooks
um and and and there just was a ton of
rhetoric flying in all directions
um and because uh the underlying
intuition was that uh whoever got to
write the history
got to write the meaning
that
youth
in school
would
take away as the meaning of the american
experience
and so
there was a great fight over
control of textbooks particularly in
american history
so that led
us to think about
doing
an experiment on textbooks
this comes from
riding on the
most recent cces
national election study
and what we wanted to do was to
accomplish two things one is to see if
we could get some idea of uh of a
gradient
in the willingness to
accept diversity
and so in one condition people were
asked about textbooks reflecting ethnic
diversity cultural diversity
and in third condition
ethnic and cultural diversity but the
heart of it was
that randomly they were assigned to
conditions where they were asked whether
they would agree or disagree with
textbooks being either written to
reflect the ethnic and cultural
diversity of america
or rewritten
to reflect the ethnic and cultural
diversity of america
uh if you take a look at the table you
can see
right away it doesn't matter as it were
how many dimensions of diversity
are involved
what does matter and what matters a lot
is whether people are being asked
to approve the project of textbooks
being written to reflect this diversity
or being
rewritten to reflect this diversity and
if you look at the bottom table you'll
see that
that's a distinction that not
surprisingly
really cuts
for the historic national majority
white americans
doesn't make a difference at all
for minorities
now
a status quo hypothesis if it would
correct
would suggest that there should be a
great deal of opposition on the part of
national majority
to the history of america being
written to reflect
the
ethnic and cultural diversity
um
and that then why because that's not the
message of the textbooks that they grew
up on
it would mean that they're acknowledging
that there is a change in the status quo
uh but but that's not clearly what's at
stake here
um
there's something about uh the about
rewriting
that is a goad
um
and that uh provokes a a kind of um
hostile opposition and you know one
possibility and is that um that that
it's a goat because it it opens up in
people's mind the the the possibility of
of of having to negotiate
about the meaning of um your national
experience about somehow having to sit
down and come away with agreement with
people on the other side about
what's acceptable to them as well as to
what's acceptable to you
and another i think you know a better
bet
um is that uh rewritten carries with it
the connotation that the meaning that
they had taken of the american
experience is to be rejected and there's
a new one that's going to be put in its
place
i don't i don't doubt
that
that if uh if there's an actual
proposal to redistribute power that that
will just be unacceptable
there there's something about this
frontier that people are being asked to
to cross
um
that i can see part of but uh but i
can't but i can't see it um all clearly
um
but the heart of it i i'm i'm i'm i'm
going to bed
has to do with the issue of ownership
um
and this is a final experiment i was
trying to figure out
how
we might
make that issue
intelligible salient
to individuals
and thought about uh the
the
about drawing and distinction between
positively affirming
the
values and traditions of a minority
and taking on
an obligation
to uh see that those traditions and
values
of a minority are secure
so
these
come from another general population
survey in america
and half the time
respondents were asked
whether or not the values and conditions
of
immigrants
have to talk about muslims
should be respected or they should be
protected
um and um
and there's just this striking
difference this
this line that people
uh start
that they balk at
um
i've i guess i've gotten more and more
persuaded
about
um
if you've actually been able to
cut as the phrase used to be nature at a
joint
then you ought to be able to replicate
results
even in
circumstances that are very different
from the ones that gave you the original
idea for doing the experiment
so thanks to colleagues at the
university of bergen
the experiment
was repeated there on their general
population sample
and
and and and the results
if i didn't give you the zip code of the
country
you wouldn't know which one was norway
and which one was america
conclusion
i want to
i want to underline three
points
the the first is that um
that the research on the clash of
cultures
and quite possibly including my own
has been deeply misleading
i am i am quite confident uh that uh
there there'll be circumstances where um
especially in in western europe
um
differences over what's regarded as
right and proper
will flare up
politically
but the fundamental motive
force
behind the concern for culture
is
is a fear of those who are different
and it's a fear that
arises not because of a commitment to
the values of your own culture
but because of a deep disposition
to intolerance
so
genuine
clash of values
and
that's
a problem
but a problem that can be handled
i'm really quite confident through
mutual accommodation
the hypernationalism that goes along
with a perceived threat to culture
that i see as a genie that has gotten
out of the bottle in some countries
greece
being the one that comes
to mind
quickest
and finally um and i never expected that
i'd come away with this view
um
because multiculturalism has uh been so
divisive
does not mean that it is necessarily so
on the contrary given the results that
we have and there's
there's a squadron of experiments that
are now being
put in the field
um i think that we're going to be able
to identify conditions
under which
politicians
can
stand behind
multiculturalism
without paying
a
a price for it
that presently
discourages them from doing so
questions
yeah
the
questions that were asked
in norway
on
the netherlands
did you also ask people about their
social
circumstances
um
certainly the political argument in
denmark also norway has been a welfare
state argument i think through these
things there's a necessity to protect
the social compound so i'm curious how
how when you started and hopefully these
are different groups when you when you
look at the subgroups within the
population is there any substantial
difference across that based on local
ethnic mix
or economic opportunity or their
expectations about participating in the
welfare state
in in in in the studies that i've
designed
which does not include the danger study
um we've had
items on um that
aim to assess the likelihood of contact
uh with an ethnic minority at work or
when you go shopping or where you live
always without success
although it is not clear to me
that
that the problem isn't
up
isn't fundamentally a problem of
measurement
i just have no idea how valid and
reliable those measures are in general
population surveys
i know i've always been impressed by
work that
don forbes has done
that whatever is observed at the
individual level between measures of
contact and
measures of inclusion
at the aggregate level
it's strikingly
stable
that the greater the diversity the
greater the animosity
the other thing you asked me about was
social economy
right um
i wish i could uh uh
and since i have so many friends who are
sociologists
report that uh we find that um
that it matters very much
um
at any rate for the for what i'm
studying
um
once you take education out of it
um the other measures that we have of
income and status don't contribute very
much at all
and i and i'm and i'm and i'm i'm and
i'm more confident of that um in
with our american data sets than i than
i am of uh with the
western european data sets
i understand
better what
for example measures of education assess
i have more confidence
in the
validity of answers to questions on
income
in america than i do
in the study in italy
which we could have saved our money and
just not asked them about income at all
because the last thing they were going
to do is to tell us how much their
income truly is
so um
no
we don't get a lot of mileage out of
that
yes alan um
to what extent do you think that's
helpful at eliminating what sort of
dispositions individuals who are more
likely to
be just
you know hyper vigilant and frightened
of all
varieties of threats
and then also
uh
very concerned about immigration just as
a personality it's a it's a kind of
personality model
it's a it's a personality model that is
you know according to the unfolding of
paid
based on
group models of evolution and whatnot so
it's a anyway i i'm going to stop at
this point and just ask you if
you're familiar with it if you find it
at all
well i'll start with saying i'm an owner
of the book
okay um and uh the second thing i'll say
is that um as i started to read through
the
introductory chapters
my heart sank
there's just so much in the way of
lumber of assumptions
the third is notwithstanding being a
fair-minded person
um
in
one of the studies that we did in two
years ago
we included short form
versions
of
heights measures
i think
in all
we took eight uh we is
uh ted carmine's and and i
um
and
uh
so so what's what is one of the problems
of
of
of thinking in terms of
of
hypothetical constructs like personality
and
for me
one of the
the first and worst is the tendency to
multiply
um
constructs
um
i mean before you know it you have like
six seven eight
and then you uh just look empirically
and ask whether or not
you have any grip on uh which of them
you know comes first or is more central
uh and which of them comes
next or is more peripheral and and for
me
the the measures that i've used
and particular this measure of
psychological tolerance that was
developed by harrison gough
um
are um
they're they're they're extraordinarily
powerful
uh they are robust in a way that um that
i find mind-boggling um the
cpi tall was developed in 1948
in minneapolis minnesota
to assess anti-semitism and uh as i said
yesterday it's its method of validation
is criterion validation so there's
nothing in the content of the items that
refers to the groups of any kind
i think that the item that i gave as an
example yesterday was most people are
honest chiefly through fear of getting
caught
so there's no way by reading the content
of the item that a respondent could know
that there's a there's some measure of
um hostility towards um
towards an out group
um
we took that measure and um as it were
flew it over to italy uh well harrison
um
did us a great service and
personally selected five
of the
35 items that make up the scale
and as it happens the cpi itself has
been translated in many languages so we
didn't have a problem with translation
and
it behaved
in the italian data just exactly as its
counterpart behaved in the uh first
study on race that we did in america
and then we
used it in the
dutch study
where there was a hazard of translation
and it behaves just
as
it's as well behaved there as it is
elsewhere so
you said free association
when i was in graduate school
um
there there was a um
the object lesson in what not to do
and how not to do it was the
authoritarian personality
um
boys they just got torn apart by by by
people who were really very very very
clever
um
and i can't think actually of a
criticism that was made of that work
uh that uh
that that i
reject i think they're valid
and nonetheless
um the authoritarian personality the
got the heart of the matter right
um
and um
it it
not the stories about the heart of the
matter but it got the heart of the
matter right that there's
people can be reliably
rank ordered along a continuum
according to the degree intensity and
frequency of the
hostility towards
towards out groups and um and and the
analysis of conformity
is i think exactly uh on the money
and it's not altogether clear to me that
um
uh
i don't use the f scale
uh but it's not clear to me that if you
if you took
whether it's height or anybody else
and and and asked about the whether
there's an additional explanatory power
that you get in the analysis of
prejudice
um i'm i'm i am open to the idea that um
that it's that that instruments that
have really been thought through
uh like the big five that there may be a
component there
that uh distinguishes itself um
but but i think that
that the
that the test of whether or not you're
actually illuminating the matter is
whether you can
account for anything better than we
could have accounted for it 70 years ago
sure
um
you have a very sweet disposition
yeah
i was hoping you could see more what you
meant about ownership being the key
issue there's a line people know with
ownership
a little bit more about what you meant
by that
seems
quite key to the story the second one is
i wanted to push back a bit on the
emphasis on nationalism from being hyper
nationalism
so i was very struck by the statistic
that the same people were likely to
blame outsiders are likely to blame
their own group members as part of the
problem and that seems very that doesn't
fit within my model of nationalism
usually those feelings come with a
certain attitude towards your fellow
citizens that is not one of distrust and
or relative to outsiders so how is this
a story about really nationalism
okay i'm counting on you to remind me
about the first because i'm going to
start with a second
um
what what has always stayed with me
vividly um
is the
is the uh is the experience in the
united states of the
late 1950s
and the early 1960s
uh where there was uh what um came to be
known as the the radical right
um and uh
this won't mean anything to you
but the john birch society
um
um and and they are a
an exemplar in my mind of exactly this
syndrome
i mean they uh
presented themselves as
as as as patriots true patriots
and uh and their whole cause was to uh
show um how uh america was being
subverted from within
and and everybody was part of this
dwight david eisenhower
uh was not merely a dupe
but he was an active co-conspirator
um and uh this combination of um
of
of extreme nationalism
and um and and comp and complete
aversion to everything
uh
that all the institutions of your of of
your society the culture of your society
even people who
sort of nominally politically
should have been on your side
you should have seen on your side
ideologically
and it came to be tied all together in
this notion of
of hyper patriotism
and richard hofstadter
did uh
an essay on the paranoid style
um
and uh and ray wolfinger and barbara
wolfinger did
a
striking study of
of
a christian variety of the radical right
when they
met in oakland
and that is a study that
that i'd highly recommend i mean that i
really would urge you to read because i
don't know anybody who is tougher minded
than ray wolfinger who's
as insistence on the difference between
politics and psychology
and it's a remarkable portrait of the
kind of
madness
that
flared up
um and um and uh
it it it's and and when i look and uh i
mean my field's american politics so um
you know
attach whatever value you want to this
but but but but when i look at um at
what's happening in um
in parts of europe that i have not
studied
um
i mean it just seems to me that um that
there that there is exactly this kind of
madness
um
and whether it can be contained or not
um
that
that i'm that i'm not confident about
it's just really going to be a question
about whether the institutions are
strong enough to keep on on
holding things together
until
the
quality of life can improve
but but things don't always come out the
right way
you know i said that yeah anyway yeah
they don't always come out the right way
so your first question was
what you meant by ownership
yeah um so here's how i uh try and um
and think through what's going on
since for me
um
for me the what i what i do
i'm not making an argument at all for
its importance
is
you get a chance to see
what's never been seen before
but that depends
on being able to somehow
um
get
hold of an idea
just like
textbooks being written versus rewritten
or
protected versus
respected
um and and and each one
um
gives you a chance of taking
you know another step to try and
find out
um because i there's nothing that i can
deduce it from
and what i do is i keep a pad of um
of of words
that seem to me by association to be
coming
to be capturing something about what it
is that's leading me
to do what i'm doing
and i had sovereignty all over it
and then i
went no i don't think that's right and i
crossed you know it out and and i wrote
ownership and um
i and and and somehow that seems to me
that's evocative uh but um but but how
to nail it
uh that i haven't figured out yet
um
i mean that uh that at some
point people are are saying you're
asking us
boy this gets me back to cultural
identity
you're asking um us to say that we're no
longer who we are
or something else
and
and that's
just where i'm going to draw the line
we own this culture
um
so so having told you that uh cultural
identity is is not the heart of the
matter
or
to the extent that it is it's it's
driven by prejudice
um
i i guess that there's a i have a view
of it that um
that there's um that
that there that there's a substantial
majority
and it's it's
so and and and what i'm looking for is
some line of consensus
it's not just the number of people who
are willing to go along
with um
affirmative support for the rights of a
minority
it's got to be that the the lines are
being drawn in a way that um
don't simply duplicate um
say for example cleavage between left
and right
i'm i'm interested in whether there are
thresholds
which
which people
on the political left share
um uh with people who are on the
political right and that's true for the
um
that's emphatically true for the for the
for the
for the experiments that i've shown you
and it's true not only in the united
states it's true in norway
where people bark is um is is where they
is
it's the same point across the political
spectrum um
yes
okay so i'm jacob hacker director of ics
and i apologize that i was out of town
yesterday and teach until 4 30. so i am
facing this comment this question on
fairly limited evidence and so tell me
that you already discussed it um so it's
actually built to some extent on what
you were just saying about the
relationship between
whether or not these are how distinct
these are from other
bundles of ideological
convictions or police and i guess i'm
just wondering how
how you think these these sets these
attitudes form i know that's a big
question and also
what accounts for some of the
differences not big but real that you
see across countries in them and is it
you know you you suggested in your last
in your set of remarks about what's
happening today that there's that
there's obviously these are powerful
external forces uh
uh that will heighten
will make more
and so
but i'm i'm interested in this since
this is your forte really is
understanding the genesis of these as
individual
beliefs interested in your in their
sense of
where these come from and how
they vary across societies and
why it's a big question but to what
extent do you feel like you have some
purchase on it
i'll i'll give you all
of the purchase that i think i have
um
as i said my field's american politics
and one
i want to insist only one of the areas
is race
and
but it's one that i've i've thought a
lot about worked a lot on and really has
shaped my intuitions
and then
i found myself
doing research
um the first country was italy
and the project was um
extra communitarians
interesting as a choice of words to
identify immigrants
in any case i
over i went
um
and um
and and as i was going there i thought
you know that they really
there's this desire to emulate america
not only america's virtues but america's
vices and as we've had a problem with
prejudice now you know my my colleagues
in sociology
are picking up a problem um
with
immigrants in
italy and especially from north africa
um
and i thought they just have no idea
what it really is like
for a society to uh be driven this way
and
so i landed in milan and my colleagues
drove me way up to trento
and i went to sleep
i got up the next morning
and went to get
coffee and
as i was going i saw this newspaper
now trantos a very rich
town in a very rich
area
and the newspaper though i i i didn't
and don't uh speak or read italian
the story was unmistakable
there was a house uh just outside
toronto where
extra communitarians lived and it had
been burned and everybody in it
had died
in the conflagration
and so i said to myself well
now you know you have no idea what's
going on here
none
and it's you better start trying to pay
attention to what's going on
um and and and that has been uh the
experience as i've gone uh from um
from
italy to the netherlands to france and
to
denmark and i've come away with this uh
this view that as deep as uh as as race
goes
in america
we're
in a position
to um
be responsive
you know in a way that um
i don't think even
uh the the best of
um
countries in western europe are are able
to
have found a way to accommodate
the idea that they really are going to
be pluralistic societies and that
and that muslims are part and parcel of
it
um
and and and and you know once you start
listing the differences um
you know the countries that
were countries of immigration not
immigration there are countries that
even though some of them are
historical fictions i mean how long has
norway been a country
um nonetheless there's this uh strong
sense of
of solidarity and um and uniformity
um
the welfare state
is is is a fundamental
uh pillar of politics
um and um
and in in in the um
in the
the book on undanish politics
there's an analysis of support for the
welfare state
and
and the conditions under which
immigrants
are included and not included
and
you know it's it's only after other
people look at your work
and
say that they find merit in it that you
can go from having a result to a finding
but the result that
one of the two results that i think
for me is most important
is that we can identify conditions under
which a commitment to the values of the
welfare state that
covenant
uh promotes
uh even handedness
just as much support for benefits going
to
to
immigrants or children of immigrants as
to
native danes
just as insistence a requirement
that danes meet
the standards of of civic obligation as
as immigrants
but those same values
for
another class of immigrants
generate uh this blatant discriminatory
outcome
okay just same same values
when it's the case of applicants being
young
even-handed
applicants being
older
just a an unmistakable double standard
the world is interesting
perverse
i don't think that you can have a true
genuine appreciation of causality unless
you have a taste for irony
so
yeah
that's good
i was going to ask you to just say more
about
could you just explain the distinction
between
values and prejudice
as clearly as possible because i wasn't
sure
but that was the key to one of your
conclusions which is the
force behind
these clashes is prejudices
dispositioned
outsiders but
is the mark of value
autonomy
is there
is that just an example of a kind of
well for for me autonomy is a canopy
term i can use it because it allows me
to um
make a connection between my work and
the work of political theorists
and it happens that
the
the
design of the instrument was rich enough
so that we can generate
a multi-indicator
index of the extent to which you value
the
the right
of individuals to develop their
abilities and outlook on lines that they
freely choose
by prejudice
i i mean
a persistent predictable systematic
readiness
to
belittle
disdain
punish or push away
members of a minority by virtue of their
membership in the minority
it is hostility that's socially focused
there there are there are there are
other features that prejudice has
stereotyping is one
rigidity is another
but so far as
my mode of research
is concerned those aren't features that
actually we can instrumentally capture
but what we can capture is individual
differences in readiness to respond
diversively punitively
to others
and that's what i mean by prejudice
sure the otherness consists partly and
you know i mean if you ask people
um i mean it frequently happens in
europe and you'll be around a
liberal-minded set of people but then
you start talking about this question of
immigration
discover that um
they don't have that
response as you expect and what you
often hear is the otherness
characterized as a matter of fact
yes it's true that in interactions with
people you can find that those you think
are um are liberal and generous in their
sympathies
uh can uh take you by surprise
and uh and respond
with a animus that you didn't expect
but i think that the more relevant point
is the one that uh you made about
otherness
when uh when we did the um italy study
um i
i think there were like
nine co-pis
at that first meeting
um
and we were trying to design the
instrument and
and i've just told you how much i know i
knew about italy
but one of the things that made this
study interesting to me the possibility
was that then there were two streams of
immigration
in italy one was from eastern europe
and the other was from north africa
and eastern europe was white
and north africa was though not entirely
mainly black
and the intuition of everybody
was that um
yes there's an animus against people
from outside the community
but the animus goes much deeper
against
people whose
skin color is black
and that just was a totally reasonable
well-founded
intuition
as it happens we designed this
experiment
um
um
and and and and the intuition behind the
experiment was this
um i thought to myself okay suppose that
i'm in a hotel room
and um and
evoking a couple stereotypes
there's a group of italians outside one
of my windows and they're
going on about
um about how we've got all of these
north africans in our country and blah
blah blah blah blah blah
anyway they're just
loud enough so i can tell that they're
mean spirited in what they're saying but
but i really can't pick up the details
and then outside my other window i got
another group of italians and and and
and they go on about you know
how
lazy and violent and criminal
um these north africans are
but then halfway through
they switch
and start talking about eastern
europeans
now all i can hear are the tones
and the question that i put to myself is
okay would i be able to tell the
difference between this group which talk
was just kept its focus on those black
faces
so this from this other group that
started off fulminating
against north africans and then rolled
over
and started to express their views about
eastern europeans anyway that's the
intuition
so
design the study so that there are two
batteries of measures of prejudice
and uh randomly
uh respondents when they come to the
first battery
the questions are always identical but
they're randomly assigned to being asked
about eastern europeans
or
about north africans
and they finished that battery of items
and then we asked him about a number of
other things and then rather late in the
interview schedule
comes the second battery of items of
prejudice
and again they're randomly assigned
to eastern europeans or north africans
now since the assignments are
independent
okay that means that we got a quarter of
the sample that are
initially asked about eastern europeans
and subsequently about eastern europeans
a quarter that are asked about north
africans and then subsequently about
north africans
a quarter they're asked about eastern
europeans and north africans north
africans and then eastern europeans so
there's actually a built-in way of
looking at order effects
now by prejudice i mean a consistent
systematic predictable readiness to
respond punitively and aversively to
members of a minority
and if that's what you mean by prejudice
the question then the test then becomes
can you distinguish those groups
in the sample
which um
responded to exactly the same group on
both occasions
from those
respondents the other half the
respondents who first were asked their
views about one group and then were
asked about their views about another
group
and the answer is no you can't
the responses are just as internet
when you switch
the group they're talking about as when
the group
is the same
um and uh and that led me to the view
that what matters is difference
it's not the particular difference
so far as prejudice is concerned it's
not that particular difference it's the
fact that you're different
and
and we did
a replication of that in the dutch study
and and found again
the same
consistency uh even when groups are
switched it doesn't mean that groups are
subjected to the same levels of
animosity that's not that doesn't follow
but it does mean that
that what what that the primary thing
that is i believe that
our results show
in this case
i'll say our findings
that it's it's difference itself which
sets you apart
on whites or with respect to blacks
and hispanics i was thinking with
respect to blacks and hispanics
no i was thinking white's asking why
it's the same set of questions with the
out groups being blacks and hispanics so
the same exact design right i know i
haven't but i think that um that one one
of the ways that we're living in a world
that's new
is that
it's now necessary
to uh step back and say okay
whites
how do they respond to blacks and
hispanics blacks how do they respond to
hispanics
and
ditto for hispanics i mean
you're not quite the same age as i but
it's this
it's the same i grew up in uh in america
where it
where the division
where it was race that was at the heart
of everything
and and we're now um
we're now in um in an era in which the
question is not merely whether or not
the historic majority except
uh minorities
um in a way happily we're in a position
where minorities now have a degree of
agency
that they didn't have before
and how exactly they behave
that really is
that's a fascination
i think
we need to uh need to fold we're 5 30
are
thank
we